To generate a web application, you can use the web
app factory. Simply putting some details of what you want
to build here for this demo, we will implement. Graphing
Implements a graphing calculator. Save your idea. Make
sure that you have some models selected. We're going to
be using Gemini Threat 3 Flash Preview. For this demo
you do have to have an image model selected even
if you aren't using it. It doesn't have to be
actually an image model. You just have to select something
And then we go to pipeline and build web app
This is the only step in this pipeline, but this
step is quite involved. It starts by generating a Project
plan of tasks and then executes them. Appropriately
keeping in mind all of their dependencies and as you
will see in a moment. Here
we see the project plan with 5 different tasks. It's
currently, of course these nodes are not displaying correctly, but
we can view the tasks themselves here. So
here it creates the foundational documents for the project, the
HTML structure. Visual style. Now it's implementing
the core logic. And once it is complete, the web
app UI will update. The implementation step
is done, and we can see the Read me in
the project root. At this point we can download the
zip if you want. Also notable is that this
application has Git support integrated into it. If you know
what Git is, it's a version, if you don't know
what Git is, it is a version control system that
essentially allows you to Sure
what that error was about, but It did save the
files to get. Now that the implementation
is done, we can also launch the app. And here
we see. We are plotting sin of x. What happens
if we say sin of x plus 10 of x
Here we go. That looks about right. Or what about
divide instead of times? What about Times. Oh
power, that looks interesting. Anyway, it seems to work, but
you know what? It's too bright. Let's
ask for some changes. Update. We can update our web
app using the updateator, and we can say, Implement
a dark theme. And a theme. Save
our notes and run the update. This will update our
project with our requested updates. This can also be useful
if you see bugs or want to. Feature or really
any change. The update is done. Let's go look at
our caffeine calculator, refresh it, and oh. You've got a
theme button and it works. So that's how to use
the web app factory to generate your own applications. We
can also collect usage. And we can see that this
entire project demo cost 11 cents so far. I
hope you find this useful.